we're very grateful I'm very happy to be
here how crazy is that that is our first
season and we were nominated for I think
seven or eight awards we get to go to
events together and it's nice to have
them the ladies of Riverdale get the
blue carpet at the 2017 and choice award
show it's such a breakout hit where do
you want to see it go from here I want
to see a good darker and that's what
we're definitely doing a season two were
exploring a lot more into these
characters and particularly with Betty
going getting in touch with her dark
side a little bit so that's fun for me
everything is taken to the next level
really feels like level one with season
one and level two it's easy - and the
storylines are great the relationships
are being more fully fleshed out that's
great how have you guys come together
and gotten close as a cast through all
of the pamorah I work with my best
friends and that's rare and I'm just
again just these are my best friends
like I'm here with my best friends and
can I say best friends one more time
yeah like they're my family
honestly I could tell them anything I'm
sharing this really bizarre experience
with them and we're all kind of in the
same boat so many rabid fans already are
if you had any crazy fan encounters yet
I was at the Grove it was right after we
got back from filming and a fan yelled
my name actually Carol blossom on top of
her lungs and I'd like generally
register instead running like soldier
running at me
and then jumped on me
[Music]